sie haben ja jetzt schon zu einem
anderen Mittel gegriffen in Bayern und
haben die Leute weggesperrt haben die in
der restzellen gesetzt im Moment in
München würden sie das mit Herrn Zander
also auch machen
wenn zum Beispiel wie jemand der wenn
jemand wie in der BMW Welt das Beispiel
habe ich vorhin angesprochen
Hausfriedensbruch begeht der grobe
Sachbeschädigung begegnete und ankündigt
dass er das bei nächster Gelegenheit
sobald er macht nach der entsprechenden
Personalienfeststellung von der Polizei
freigelassen wird ist wieder tot das ist
in der Tat gerechtfertigt dass ein
Richter sich mit der Frage beschäftigt
entsprechend zu jemandem auch nicht
sparsam zu nehmen und das haben Richter
angeordnet und das ist aus meiner Sicht
auch die richtige Reaktion ich muss auf
der anderen Seite aber bitte auch
feststellen es ist doch keine
Massenbewegung wenn wir mal sehen wie
viel Leute die sich da entsprechend so
aufhören die überwältigende Mehrheit die
überwältigende Mehrheit der Menschen in
Deutschland denkt eben nicht so wie er
Zander und hält auch diese Aktionen
wir stehen jetzt deswegen jetzt nicht
vor dem Kollaps diese Stapel aber wir
sagen ganz klar dass wir solche
jeden Morgen in den großen Städten in
Deutschland wie viele sind es denn
aktuell haben sie Erkenntnisse werden
das gerade immer mehr
wir haben da insgesamt keine Gesamtzahl
bislang wir beobachten das was ich jetzt
der schwerpunktmäßig gerade den letzten
14 Tagen in München getan hat dabei
waren aber sehr viele Ausländer da waren
Italiener Franzosen Spanier dabei also
es ist ja die Reisen quer durch Europa
und machen da jeweils ihre
Schwerpunktaktionen das ist stark für
noch im hintereinander
wenn wir das hören wir wissen gerade
nicht werden das immer mehr nach der
Aktion und in Berlin wo ist der heftige
Diskussion noch zurecht gab nach dem
Unfall hätte man ja gedacht okay jetzt
erstmal setze ich dann niemand mehr
Straße nicht so tun als wenn es jetzt
nur so ein paar Wissenschaftler oder
Studenten sind die das mal so nebenbei
machen sondern es ist ja relativ
organisiert hat er jetzt ein paar
Artikel gegeben dass es auch ziemlich
große Geldgeber gibt und das ist auch
ziemlich durchorganisiert ist es muss
jetzt nicht er wird ja auch verschiedene
Organisationen ich weiß nicht letzte
Generation Ende Gelände existieren
Spaghetti und so weiter Solidarisierung
aus der linken Szene und ich denke mal
bis jetzt ist es nicht terroristisch
oder keine Gewalt und so weiter aber das
kann tatsächlich jederzeit kippen denn
wenn man sich einmal den Anspruch sagt
wir müssen jetzt gehört werden also um
diesen Kipppunkt
dann dann dann dann kann es sehr leicht
sein dass man sagt es sind auch krassere
Aktionen
erlaubt das war damals muss ich aber von
der Historie sagen bei der 68er
Rebellion genauso das war hieß die waren
genauso damals wie gesagt haben Gewalt
nur gegen Sachen es hat sich dann
gesteigert dann hattest durch durch
sozusagen Zufall die ersten Toten
gegeben in München bei einer
Demonstration die auch aus dem eigenen
Lager
kam was wurde dann auch gelogen das sind
die ganzen Tage und fast niemand hat
sich so intensiv mit diesem Thema
beschäftigt wie sie
mit ihrer Arbeit journalistisch als
Autorin aber vor allen Dingen mit ihrer
Biografie natürlich auch als Tochter von
Ulrike meinhoff das heißt sie haben
gerade über diesen Kipppunkt
gesprochenpunkt
Terrorismus wird also ich würde das
jetzt vor allen Dingen als jemand sagen
der das recherchiert hat und auch
analysiert hat es hat diesen Kipppunkt
gegeben weil dann innerhalb dieser
Strukturen natürlich auch dann die
radikaleren oft sie es sind natürlich
viele Leute die mit einem guten Willen
angefangen haben wir 68 auch aber es
gibt dann es innerhalb der Strukturen
gewinnen dann oft nicht die vernünftigen
sondern immer die die noch die größere
Aktion machen wie viel besseren Werbung
machen man kämpft für eine gute Sache
das verbindet Herr Weise ich würde sagen
jeder tipppunkt hat noch nicht
stattgefunden und hoffentlich
hoffentlich findet er nicht statt aber
es ist es gibt sozusagen die Möglichkeit
wenn es Protagonisten in dieser Bewegung
sich nach oben ploppen was wir nicht
hoffen also was
findest du damals ist das auch diese
Sachen diese ganzen Rebellionen ja nicht
von unten alleine kommt sondern
angefangen an verwurzelt mit ganz
starken establishmentgrößen bei den
Grünen bei der SPD bei den Linken und
auch bei großen Geldgebern
ja das war bei 68 übrigens auch so auch
die sind damals sehr sehr früh
finanziert worden entscheidend von
großfinanzieren also davon ganz
Klarmobil das Geld Einzelspender das
sind alle die Einzelspender deswegen
sind die Privatpersonen ja
Privatpersonen sind auch ja das ist so
das sind so 100 € von meine Eltern
finanzieren mich auch so 2019 haben wir
amerikan gemacht jetzt machen wir
Straßenblockaden das ist keine
Aktionsform ich möchte was möchte
bringen einen Kipppunkt erklären Sie ein
wissenschaftlichen Punkt was ihre
Biografie angeht wo sie jetzt sagen
Gewaltfreiheit ist für mich wird aber es
könnte andere geben selber erfahren also
wo ist bei ihnen der Punkt wo sie sagen
bis dahin und auf keinen Fall weiter
ja bei allen Bewegungen die sie jetzt
genannt haben und vor allem ist die
Gewaltfreiheit der zivile Ungehorsam der
ja friedliche Ziele Ungehorsam dass Omas
der Limit da gibt es nichts es wird
nicht darüber hinausgehen jetzt wieder
Ungehorsam ist eine Form die wir
anwenden weil wir uns nicht weiter zu
helfen müssen ich würde gerne andere
Sachen machen aber mir bleibt keine
andere Wahl als Wissenschaftler mir
gehört zu schaffen
und ich muss jetzt wirklich eine Lanze
für Herrn Hermann brechen er hat nämlich
alles schon richtig gesagt er hat gesagt
ihr hängt das viel zu hoch mein Freund
Thomas hat es auch richtig gesagt was
sind denn das für Kinder die da auf der
Straße sind das ist die vierte
Generation der letzte Teebeutel Aufguss
von uns aus den 60er Jahren dass du
Augenblick dass du natürlich eine
gezeichnete bist das wissen wir jetzt
das ist leise ich dass du das
Aufarbeiten kannst
nein
ich habe darüber gesprochen deine
persönliche Biograf nein das hat er auch
gerade schon eben vorgetragen
gemacht Biografie finde ich bist du
derjenige der den ganzen Tisch hier
springt also das ist deine du bist das
ganze Ding mit 68
dass ihr das hoch hängt und dadurch so
wie du das auch befürchtest
diese ich sage trieben werden weil
Politiker also
die Politiker haben noch keine Antwort
das ist das Problem seine Leute
blockieren und sabotieren seit Jahren
Hermann inklusive der Händler Schuld die
über ihn berichten
was soll denn eigentlich passieren ich
kann nur noch einmal sagen wir haben
schon einmal die den Wald sterben gehabt
der Band 1200
Wissenschaftler die haben geschworen es
gibt nur wir haben bei einem noch aber
ich nehme an ist in der Familie
geblieben
ich musste wirklich nicht das Wort für
die klimaaktivieren machen aber ehrlich
mal jetzt geht's wissen Sie wenn du ein
Protest kommt hat er ja auch eine
Wirkung in der Gesellschaft dass die
Leute nachdenken ihre Verhalten musste
überprüfen die Industrie sich verändert
die Forschung ist stärker wird und das
passiert ist auch wieder die sind so
ungeduldig die glaube ich übertreiben es
auch da bin ich bei Ihnen wenn Sie sagen
dass ich das mal sozusagen die radikale
Position am Ende sieht und sagte sie
geht das nicht auf aber jeder Protest
hat am Ende auch was fruchtbringendes
weil in der Gesellschaft neu nachgedacht
haben
diese Leute kommen gleich zurück zu
Ihnen Herr morgen weil diese Leute ja
sagen sie glauben auch nicht an die
Veränderungsbereitschaft des Systems sie
haben jahrelang angeguckt und sie meinen
auf der besseren auf der richtigen Seite
aber das ist ich würde sagen gucken wir
uns noch mal den
atomprotest an der hat dazu geführt der
flächendeck die atomprotest in den 80er
Jahren also ich war auch hatte auch so
ein Schild der tonkraft nein danke ohne
eine Ahnung zu haben
weil natürlich war ich gegen den Atom
Tod also wer es nicht gegen den Atom Tod
aber diese Bewegung hat dazu geführt
dass Angela Merkel die Atomkraftwerke
2011 abgeschaltet hat das heißt ich sag
jetzt mal so verkürzt
aber noch nicht deswegen nicht wegen dem
Protest der 80er Jahre
Baden-Württemberg in der Kreidezeit
Protest weil er man massenhaft geführt
ist ist richtig ich halte es für falsch
dass wir Deutschland auch sehr
Atomenergie ausgestiegen sind wir wären
heute längst bei besseren
Atomkraftwerken die jetzt in China zum
Beispiel gebaut werden kleine viel
saubere das ist alles abgeschaltet
worden in Deutschland würde es viel
besser gehen und es wäre auch von der
CO2 Seite her viel besser hätten sie
auch Atome ich will nur sagen es ist
nicht immer fruchtbar wenn man auf den
Massenprotest hört der aber
wissenschaftlich sehr oft unfundiert
kommt
so sie hören auf die Wissenschaft es
passieren Veränderungen das sehe ich
ganz anders das sehe ich ganz anders
weil wo sind die Veränderungen haben sie
den Herrn Antonio guterich gehört den
Generalsekretär aktuell sagt ich Klima
die radikalen sind sondern
viele Energien
aufgehört habe jetzt kommt der Punkt
dass wir ganz entscheidende ich habe ja
gesagt so eine gesellschaftliche Debatte
die bringt auch Bewegung in die
Forschung in die polit Entscheidung das
sehen wir gerade in Deutschland sie
fokussieren sich mit dem Protest auch
sehr auf Deutschland das Entscheidende
ist und das könnte eben auch zur Wahl
dazu selbst in Deutschland alles
einhalten würden was sie Forderungen
selbst wenn wir alles umsetzen würden
was Sie wollen dann reicht das nicht
weil das Weltklima insgesamt Sicht auch
durch Entscheidungen anderen Ländern
beeinflusst und jetzt kommt es
entscheidende dazu was ich vorhin gesagt
mit unserem Wert unserer Demokratie hier
in diesem Land können sie demonstrieren
sie können sich anketten sie können auch
ein paar Tage sitzen bleiben dann werden
sie irgendwann bestraft dann können Sie
wieder hier sitzen können sie ja weiter
programmieren in Diktaturen in
unfreiheitlichen Gesellschaften können
sie das nicht machen und manchmal wäre
es auch mutig nicht nur hier in
Deutschland weil es hier und bestraft
bleibt ihrem Protest zu äußern sondern
die internationalen Kräfte von ihnen zu
unterstützen die in Ländern aktiv sind
wo es viel schwieriger ist wo sie mit
Leib und Leben solche Rechte eingreifen
müssen würden sie sich also wünschen
nicht in der Demokratie zu leben sondern
in einer Art klimadiktatur wo wir all
das was bei Ihnen auf wissenschaftlichen
Zettel in der Arbeit steht einmal
durchparken möchten
einer Demokratie leben und ich nutze
auch und ja finde es gut dass
ich finde es nicht in Ordnung dass so
mit der Wissenschaft umgegangen wird
gesagt wird ja ja ihr sagt schon das
richtige aber wir hier Thomas das war
nur Thomas
zu tun
das Problem und Deutschland ist weit weg
davon seine eigene Klimaziele
einzureichen gerade nachdenken was für
Ausreden empfindet das ist nicht
schlecht
versuche hier in dieser Sendung
herauszufinden also eine besser auf die
Masse der Wissenschaften
Sie sich also Wünschen in dieser
Ökodiktatur zu leben und all das einmal
durchzupacken ich bin sehr froh dass wir
in der Demokratie leben sind und
deswegen müssen
in diesem Land in Ordnung solange wir
nicht die Eigentumsrechte oder
Arbeitnehmer
Punkt dort wo sie andere
Sachbeschädigung machen greifen sie in
andere Rechte ein da endet ihr schließen
Sie gerade angetextet hat es geht
durch Reiches Rechnung für alle
Entwicklung ihrer Bewegung zu einer ja
Öko RAF aus ja eindeutig wir sind
gewaltfrei wir bleiben gewaltfrei